[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen den meine
taten welt heute gibt's endlich mal
wieder ein konzept von mir ich habe ich
letztes jahr schon mal auf meiner
facebook seite gepostet das foto von
diesem kuchen und viele von euch fragen
jetzt seitdem nach dem rezept ich mache
heute den kirschkuchen mit kokos
streuseln der kirschkuchen ist so
aufgebaut erst kommt da ein mürbeteig in
die form dann die kirsch masse in der
auch himbeeren sind und darüber kommen
dann eben mit streusel und diesen eben
ganz besonderes mit kokosflocken
aufbereitet und wenn ihr wissen wollt
wie das geht dann bleibt jetzt dran so
erst einmal zeige ich euch die zutaten
für den mürbeteig für den mürbeteig
braucht ihr 225 gramm mehl 100 gramm
butter 60 gramm zucker einen teelöffel
backpulver 1 eigelb und ein esslöffel
vanillezucker oder eine tüte dazu kommen
jetzt kommen einfach alle zutaten in
eine schüssel und werden zu einem
glatten teig verknetet
sobald die stadt hilft es manchmal wenn
man es sehr einfach in kleine stückchen
zerschneidet dann kann man nämlich den
teich besser verkneten
[Musik]
wenn ihr merkt dass dabei etwas zu
trocken ist und können ruhig noch ein
bisschen futter eingeben
weil ich habe da jetzt etwas weniger
butter drin wegen de michael aber
manchmal ist das einfach zu klein ist
nehme ich mir meine gefettete und
gewählte springform 26 cm durchmesser
und legt die form jetzt damit aus jetzt
müsste hier auch einen kleinen rand
hochziehen das mache ich jetzt so davor
mich mir einfach so eine wurst legt die
an den rand und dann drücke ich sehr und
fest
[Musik]
heute brauche ich keine hintergrundmusik
das übernimmt meine tochter für mich
[Musik]
denn rein strikter einfach hier am boden
fest
schneide ich einfach so weg dann habe
ich nämlich einen sauberen run mit in
den boden einarbeiten
[Musik]
auch nicht mehr perfekt sein da kommen
ja später noch streusel drüber g20 den
boden mehrmals einstechen
das verhindert einfach dass der dreieck
später blasen wirft
und während ich jetzt die füllung zu
bereit gebe ich den kuchen also den teig
so lange in den kühlschrank damit der
map pack schön kalt bleibt für die
füllung braucht ihr ein glas shoppen
wollen oder sauerkirsch mit saft ihr
braucht 200 gramm himbeeren aus dem
tiefkühlfach oder 200 gramm frische
himbeeren
ihr braucht etwas saft zum auffüllen ich
nehme da jetzt eine traube himbeersaft
es geht aber auch und kirschsaft oder
anrainer himbeersaft 1 esslöffel
vanillezucker 45 gramm speisestärke und
40 gramm zucker
ihr müsst natürlich nicht zwingend jetzt
kirschen und himbeeren benutzen als
früchte
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch ganz gute
nektarinen oder aprikosen benutzen
bist du einfach immer darauf achten dass
ihr eben einen teil früchte oder obst
benutzt und in anderen teil dann durch
saft ersetzt also da könnt ihr
eigentlich wirklich vieles ausprobieren
was ich mir auch gut vorstellen kann
wer zb ebenso eine mischung aus mango
ananas das passt ja auch ganz gut zu dem
kongress flocken
wie gesagt ich mag das ganz gerne mit
kirschen und mithin bahn und ihr könnt
es so machen wie ihr wollt
ich möchte jetzt zuallererst die kirchen
abgießen den saft müsste aber auffangen
ihr braucht er nämlich 500 milliliter
saft
sagte ich mir jetzt kurz hier drauf
jetzt müsst ihr den saft ab messen und
hier seht ihr dass ich nur 400 metern ab
jetzt nehme ich meinen hersteller
himbeer traubensaft und fülle auf 500
milliliter auf davon gehe ich jetzt das
meiste hier rein und lasso etwa sagen
wir mal sechs esslöffel übrig um das
eben mit gleich mit der stärke
aufzuhören
den saft lasse ich jetzt hier aufkochen
und währenddessen rührig die
speisestärke an
[Musik]
auch zudem kirschsaft hier dazu dann
kann sich der zucker nämlich schön
auflöst wenn das sah man kocht können da
die starke mischung ein vielleicht
einmal noch kurz vorher durchführen
und sogleich den herd ausschalten und
jetzt können hier schon mit rein
einrühren und dann noch die himbeeren
und dann vielleicht ein bisschen
größeren topf als ich mit dem gefrorenen
himmlisches hat super weil die ja so
kalt sind könnt ihr die masse richtig
schön runter dann können wir sie nämlich
gleich auf den mittag streichen weil es
die mischung schon schön kalt ist kann
ich sie auch direkt auf meine website
geben einfach in die mitte schritten
schön verteilen und so wieder gucken
jetzt bei 220 minuten vor gebacken
wir haben da fuhren vor bugs können wir
schon mal die streusel vorbereiten
dafür braucht ihr 150 gramm mehl 50
gramm kokosraspeln 50 gramm zucker und
etwa 85 gramm butter
ihr könnt die kokosraspeln natürlich
auch durch mandeln oder durch haselnüsse
ersetzen
aber ich mache es jetzt in meinem rezept
und genau wie frauen bei mürbeteig
werden die daten jetzt einfach kurz
verrührt verknetet das könnte ich auch
mit der hand machen oder eben mit den
mit dem handrührgerät mit den knethaken
[Musik]
entstanden ist könnte die streichung zur
seite legen und einfach warten bis der
kuchen so weit ist
ich mag die straße ganz gerne mit kokos
ich finde das passt super zu den kirchen
und zu den himbeeren ihr könnt aber auch
stadt denn der cocos straße zum beispiel
auch mandel nehmen oder haselnüsse oder
eben alles was euch schmeckt ihr könnt
die cocos streusel aber auch einfach
weglassen und die stattdessen durch mehl
ersetzt
also das ist wirklich nicht zwingend
vorgegeben dass ihr da die cocos
streusel benutzt weil ein chorus mag
lässt sie weg und ersetzt sie einfach
durch etwas anderes
nach ca 20 minuten sieht der kuchen dann
so aus dass ihr könnt sehen der hand
hier ist schon leicht braun
das ist die optimale farbe
da kommen da jetzt die streusel drüber
vorsichtig dass ihr euch nicht verbrennt
so schön gleichmäßig verteilt und so
wird der kuchen jetzt weitere 20 minuten
fertig gebacken wenn ihr merkt dass die
straße zudem die beiden dann schaut euch
einfach runter auf 170 grad
so sieht mein kuchen dann nach dem
backen aus ich werde jetzt einmal
komplett abkühlen lassen und rändern
später erst den springform rand ab mein
kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt ich hatte den
mit einem geschirrhandtuch überdeckt und
jetzt werde ich hier vorsichtig den rand
lösen
[Musik]
damit sollen mit einer palette darunter
und löst erst mal den boden lag und
damit sich so einfach rüber
und wer jetzt noch möchte kann den kann
der kurve mit puderzucker bestäuben oder
kann ihn auch so lassen
ich finde das sieht immer ganz nett aus
und dann ist hier spuren auch schon
fertig
ich hoffe dieses rezept video gefällt
euch im prinzip könnt ihr ja den kuchen
so waren wie ihr wollt dass ich einfach
so ein grundrezept für streuselkuchen
wie schon vorhin erwähnt könnt ihr eben
gewisse zutaten ersetzen oder
austauschen und dann wünsche ich euch
jetzt viel spaß damit wünsche euch noch
eine schöne zeit und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]